for years some locals complained about
over tourism where there were just too
many people crowding the hot spots and
the streets of kyoto but now that the
pandemic has hit the businesses hard
many of them all want the same thing
for the taurus to return and open their
wallets
japan one of the world's most popular
travel destinations relaxed its kobit 19
border restrictions and reopened to
foreign tourists after more than two
years
businesses in the ancient capital kyoto
are hoping to welcome back visitors
[Music]
yuksen is a high-end kimono shop that
combines traditional japanese garments
with famous inkwash paintings to create
one-of-a-kind modern wear
now
without many tourists
turned his kimono shop into a french
restaurant as a way to get some
customers through the door
hotels have also struggled
with
says business is just 10 to 30 percent
of what it was before the pandemic
over at city hall mayor kadokawa who's
been in office since 2008 gives us his
take
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
nishiki is a popular covered shopping
street known as kyoto's kitchen
the often crowded market discourages
visitors from eating while walking
plastering signs about the rules but now
it may be taking a softer approach
[Music]
as tourists from both japan and overseas
slowly start filling up the streets
again chopping areas like
are gearing up for another boom
tsujiri tea house was founded back in
1860.
during the covet pandemic it closed up
shop and leaned into its online store
but now these doors are wide open once
again
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
you